THE APP STORE:
In 2021, the Apple App Store brought in a
total of $85 billion worth of revenue out of which
Apple’s cut of is about $20 to $25 billion. This
itself is insane, but if we look at it in terms of
profit, things become even crazier. Historically,
the App Store has boasted an operating margin of
78% meaning that $17.5 billion of this is pure
profit. For perspective, Apple as a whole nets
$114 billion per year meaning that the App Store
alone accounts for over 15% of Apple’s entire
bottom line. Apple currently boasts a valuation
of just under $3 trillion with $114 billion worth
of profit. So, with $17.5 billion worth of profit,
you could argue that the App Store itself is worth
roughly $460 billion. That would make the iOS App
Store the 15th largest company in the world.
Even if you want to be super conservative and
cut that valuation in half, we’re still talking
about a market cap of $230 billion which would
still make the App Store roughly the same size
as Coca Cola or Toyota. And when you zoom out,
this is really not all that surprising given that
the App Store was responsible for $1.1 trillion
worth of transactions in 2022. For perspective,
even Amazon only boasts half that revenue,
but forget companies. With $1.1 trillion worth of
essentially GDP value, the App Store would rank as
the 17th largest country by GDP. But it wasn’t
an easy journey getting here. In fact, Apple
initially didn’t even have plans of launching
such an App store, and Steve Jobs insistence of
doing everything the Apple way has caused quite
a bit of trouble for Apple in regards to the App
Store. So here’s the full story of the Apple App
Store and how powerful the App Store really is.
ACCIDENTIAL INVENTION:
With how successful the app
store has become, you probably think that this was
always part of Apple and more specifically Steve
Jobs’ grand vision for the iPhone, but that’s not
actually the case. In fact, the original iPhone
didn’t even have an app store, and while Apple
was working on an app store in the background,
it wasn’t meant to be something big. It was
just supposed to be a place where users could
download auxiliary apps from Apple themselves.
In fact, Apple had no intention of letting 3rd
party developers onto the App Store at all. Steve
Jobs figured that developers could just create
web apps that could be run on Safari. This would
be easier for developers to adapt their existing
platforms and easier for Apple as they wouldn’t
have to police the app store. But developers
weren’t exactly a massive fan of this idea. They
would protest on forums and purposefully avoid
creating mobile versions of their web apps. But,
what really pushed things over the edge was the
jailbreaking community. Just a few days after the
iPhone launched, developers would put together a
jailbreak for it. And just a few weeks after this,
the jailbreaking community would come out with the
world’s first iPhone game called Lights Off.
Lights Off was a very simple straight forward
game that never really caught on but it’s what
it represented that really mattered. This game
was an assertion from the developer community that
if Apple wasn’t going to directly allow for native
development, they were just gonna do it on their
own, and that’s exactly what happened. In October
of 2007, the community would release an easily
accessible jailbreak called AppSnapp which came
with it’s own app store called Installer.app. This
would quickly evolve into Cydia which I’m sure
you’re all familiar with and it’s what finally got
Steve Jobs off his high horse. The same month that
Installer.app was released, Jobs would issue an
open letter to the developer community. He didn’t
quite apologize for his previous stance but he
did announce that a native App Store was coming
very soon. Imagine if Jobs hadn’t relented. Cydia
would’ve became magnitudes larger than it did as
a lot more developers would’ve jumped on board.
Apple may have even been forced to support Cydia
at one point if it became wide spread enough, but
fortunately for Apple, Jobs made the right choice
and launched their own App Store on July 10, 2008
with just over 500 apps. On paper, the launch
was a massive success. Within just the first
weekend, the App Store would reach 10 million
downloads. Just 2 months later, they would reach
100 million downloads, and within just 9 months,
they would reach 1 billion downloads. But putting
these insane numbers aside, Apple was actually
having quite a tough time internally because Steve
had insisted on doing everything the Apple Way.
THE APPLE WAY:
Despite technically giving
developers what they wanted with the app store,
Apple was still receiving a bunch of backlash
from developers. Likely the biggest reason for
this was that Apple was forcing developers to use
Apple tools to make apps: Xcode and UIKit. Since
then, we have seen alternatives and more neutral
languages pop up like Flutter but the bread and
butter of iOS development is still Xcode which a
lot of developers are still quite salty about.
In fact, that’s why Xcode has a relatively low
rating of 3.1 stars. It’s not that Xcode is bad
per se but simply that a lot of developers are
still pissed off that they’re forced to use it.
But, this is issue with developers was the least
of Apple’s concerns when it came to the App Store.
Likely their biggest issue was actually supporting
the insane scale of iOS development. With
something like Windows, this was never a problem
because Microsoft doesn’t really control what can
be installed on Windows machines. So, all they had
to do was create an open platform and support
a broad range of implementations. Everything
else was up to developers whether it be testing or
distribution or scale. The same however could not
be said about the App Store. You see, while Apple
allows developers to make apps for their various
devices, iOS is still not an open platform. It’s
more of a quasi open platform as every single line
of code that makes its way on to the App Store
has to be manually reviewed by Apple. On one side,
this largely limits what developers can and cannot
do, and that’s why jailbreaking and Cydia were so
big despite the App Store. On the other side,
this ensures that everything on the App Store
is of a certain level of quality and doesn’t
contain malware or viruses or anything harmful.
That’s why all iOS apps have certain aura about
them when it comes to UI and completeness. But,
this also means that Apple has to manually review
every single version of every single app. Yeah,
I think you can see why that would be rather
hard to manage, and Apple doesn’t take these
reviews lightly either. Of course, you’ll hear
about something that slipped through the cracks
here and there. For example, they once accidently
approved an app that would straight up let users
jailbreak their iPhone, but for the most part,
Apple’s review system is very robust. In fact,
40% of App Store submissions are rejected
largely due to nitpicky things. For example,
a keyboard might’ve been partially covering up
a textfield which made the UI not as pristine.
Sometimes Apple will even reject an app on the
basis that they don’t think its valuable to
users. But not only does Apple pride themselves
in picking out the smallest of mistakes but they
aim to do it within 24-48 hours. Yeah, I don’t
think you’d be surprised to hear that Apple has
500 people working full time to review iOS apps.
But not only is the App Store labor intensive,
it’s also capital intensive. Going back to Windows
for example, if you wanna download Photoshop, you
would head to Adobe’s website, and it would be up
to Adobe to ensure that their website and servers
can scale to the demand. With the App Store,
however, it’s all up to Apple. Aka, they currently
have to support 142 billion downloads every single
year. With the average iOS app being 34 MB, we’re
talking about 4.8 exabytes of data or 4.8 million
terabytes worth of downloads every single year.
Clearly, following the Apple way with the App
Store has cost Apple quite a bit, but fortunately
there was gold at the end of the rainbow which
brings us into the economics of the App Store.
THE APPLE TAX:
Apple has a few ways of monetizing the App
Store starting with directly charging developers.
Every year, each developer has to pay Apple $100.
Technically, there is a free tier that you could
use to mess around with coding iOS apps, but if
you actually want your app to end up on the App
Store, you gotta have the paid tier. As of 2022,
Apple had a total of 34 million registered
developers. How many of these developers
are on the paid tier is unclear, but it’s very
possible that this fee alone generates over a
billion dollars in annual revenue for Apple. Given
how much Apple makes off the App Store though,
this pales in comparison which brings us into
Apple’s main mode of monetization: the Apple tax.
For apps that generate less than $1 million per
year, developers have to pay 15% to Apple. And for
apps that generate more than $1 million per year,
developers have to pay 30%. Recently, these fees
have gotten a lot of criticism as being the 30%
Apple tax that’s applied to all revenue that goes
through the App Store, but that’s not quite how it
works. I mean think about it, $1.1 trillion worth
of revenue goes through the App Store. If Apple
charged 30% on all of that, that itself would be
$330 billion worth of revenue or a wholenother $3
trillion company. While the App Store is extremely
lucrative, it’s no where near that lucrative.
In reality, Apple actually only makes $20 to $25
billion per year from the App Store. So, in terms
of percentages, they’re only earning 2 to 2.5% of
the revenue that passes through the App Store. And
this is how Apple largely defends their 30% fee,
but that’s not to say that the fee is small
like Apple claims either. The reality is that
Apple’s fee is quite large but not to the people
that you might think. Take Amazon, for example.
They don’t release official revenue stats for
their desktop website vs their mobile app, but
according to sellers, it’s usually about a 60/40
split with the majority coming from mobile. Aka,
Amazon pulls in nearly $300 billion every year
thanks to their iOS and Android apps. But,
it’s not like they’re paying $100 billion to Apple
and Google who by the way has nearly an identical
pricing model with the Play Store. How do you they
avoid this massive fee you ask? Well, it’s not due
to some sort of secret background deal though
they do have that as well. The real secret is
simply that Amazon has the authority to directly
charge customers. Almost everyone has their credit
card directly linked with Amazon, so Amazon has
virtually no need Apple’s payment infrastructure
which is where the Apple tax actually applies.
It’s basically the same case with every other
big company or financial platform. These guys
can charge you directly, so they don’t have
to deal with the Apple tax. The only notable
exception to this rule is streaming services.
People often subscribe to streaming services out
of impulse, and these streaming giants don’t want
to lose out on customers by slowing down the
process and asking for credit card details. So,
they’ll often just use Apple’s double click to pay
stuff. With that being said, you should be careful
when subscribing to these services through Apple
because it’s often more expensive. YouTube Premium
for example normally costs $14 per month. But, if
you buy it through the app using Apple’s payment
infrastructure, it’s $19 per month to account for
the 30% tax. So, all of the big companies that
account for the vast majority of the $1 trillion
going through the App Store don’t even have to pay
Apple a dime if they don’t want to. The people who
actually end up paying Apple boat load is smaller
developers who are solely dependent on Apple’s
payment infrastructure which is usually game
developers. People like RobTop from Geometry Dash,
Supercell from Clash of Clans and Clash Royale,
or Nintendo who have been trying to fight
the Apple tax for years. It seems that
Microsoft has also joined this fight which is not
surprising given their recent gaming acquisitions,
but the Apple tax still stands. Even if the Apple
tax eventually comes down though, while it would
be a nice break for smaller developers, it doesn’t
really matter for Apple because in the end,
it doesn’t really change how powerful the
Apple App Store really is. With historically
high interest rates, the appeal bills and bonds is
the higher than ever, yet traditional brokerages
haven’t really adapted with the times. They
still expect people to use clunky bond tables,
scroll through long overwhleming lists, and even
use virtual keyboards till recently. And that’s
why we created our own modern bond platform: Silo.
At Silo, we prioritize the user experience and the
ease of finding and investing in the issuers you
know and trust, so that you too can lock in high
yields. Also, choosing a strong user experience
doesn’t mean sacrificing on safety. Every Silo
account is insured by $500,000 in SIPC insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC insurance. Also, all
funds deposited on the platform will be maintained
by our trusted custodian, Interactive Brokers,
who has experience managing $373 billion
worth of assets over the past 45 years. So,
if you’re looking for a modern way to invest
in bonds, please consider checking out Silo
in the description below. If you think the
Apple App Store is too powerful, you check
out Android because they’re on a wholenother
level. Check out this video to learn more.